ja aber es ist ja immer ansehen du bist
hässlich
hallöchen freunde und willkommen bei
einem neuen projekt dieses projekt ist
die to have a show zusammen mit den
adrett ohne skin gehe und dass wir kein
skin haben liegt ganz einfach daran dass
im moment die minecraft server seit dem
1 0 3 update wieder so ein paar probleme
dass man manchmal keines kindheit aber
das hält uns gar nicht davon ab die
direkt jetzt endlich das große teile
oder alle haupt bleche nein wir wollen
es gar nicht selbst loben aber wir
wollen euch in dieser folge mal ein
wenig darüber erzählen wie wir das
geplant haben warum wir jetzt nochmal
genau eine neue welt angefangen haben
und wie genau es auch besser sein wird
als das alte to gather und ich würde
sagen du kannst endlich direkt mal
anfangen zu quatschen oder er hat das
ding ist wir hatten ja davor dann das
together an sich laufen ganz normales
together und jetzt haben wir uns ein
komplett neues konzept überlegt was es
so wahrscheinlich noch gar nicht gibt
und zwar darum hat es auch diesen diesen
namen
die trailershow mit konkreter und dehner
und erstmal das jetzt in den ersten zwei
folgen das sind ausnahmen da werden wir
erst mal hier zu zweit und zu ein
bisschen was bauen dass wir zumindest
jetzt mal nicht komplett im nichts
stehen
und dann werden immer für erst mal
jeweils vier folgen gäste kommen und ich
irgendwelche gäste sondern erwehren und
schon ein paar leute suchen die ihr auch
dann zu großen teilen kennt und ihr
könnt uns auch immer in die kommentare
schreiben
wenn ihr den er gerne sehen wollt und
gerne macht es bitte dann auch dass sie
den kommentaren daumen hoch geht wohl
denkt der sollte kommen und ich als 1000
dreifach reinschreiben sondern was er
nämlich auch machen könnte es themen in
die kommentare schreiben wir haben
natürlich für diese folge und für die
nächsten folgen insgesamt schon über 20
themen uns verschiedene rausgesucht aber
wir werden natürlich auch immer eure
themen dann suchen bzw auch verwenden
werden euch dann erwähnen und so weiter
wenn ihr irgendwelche themenvorschläge
habt über das wir reden sollen einfach
unten in die kommentare kritzeln mit
magic und dann sehen wir das schon ganz
fett noch einmal schön mit dem edding
reinschreiben auf dem bildschirm das
freut die mama und auf jeden fall auf
eine super sache also wir dann
wahrscheinlich schon euch so langsam so
zusammen aus den aus den einzelnen
wortfetzen die wir von uns geben könnt
euch dann wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
zusammenreimen dass wir hier und seien
praktisch eine welt aufbauen und dann
immer gäste haben die sich dann
praktisch auch mit dem haus verewigen so
ähnlich wie das ja bereits in unserem
ersten liga war aber diesmal einfach
besser organisierte sogar es war
wirklich früher so dass wir teilweise
zwar zwischendurch so zwei wochen
aufnahme pause dann kamen zwei folgen
dann war wieder eine woche gar nichts
wir werden regelmäßige hochladen ich
habe zum beispiel jetzt weniger projekte
ihr seht dieses video ja gerade nach
meinem nach meiner vorstellung von dem
neuen konzept wir haben auch extra für
diese show hier schon ein neues intro
also sollte ich wirklich so ein bisschen
ich sag mal etablieren dass ihr wisst
euro kultur peter scholer kommt extra
dieses und dieses intro speziell für
diese show hat wirklich wie sonne wie
seine tv-show sage ich mal ein bisschen
von den sternen gegriffen aber so soll
es auf jeden fall ein bisschen aufgebaut
sein mit einem eigenen intro und so
weiter werden anhalt eure themen
durchsprechen ab und zu ein paar gäste
und ja das war es doch eigentlich schon
so grob und nicht nur ab und zu ein paar
gäste sondern es zählt jedes jedes mal
für vier folgen
ein gast dabei und nach diesen vier
folgen wird es da noch die welt zum
download geben also steuert und sondern
biete nicht mehr da sind diamanten
diamant ja aber eigentlich sonst auch
ganz genau einerseits wird von uns
gelöscht aber andererseits ist uns
eigentlich egal bzw
es kommt nicht darauf an dass wir ja so
feifel wir gehen jetzt eine hülle machen
jetzt die sondern es kommt wirklich
darauf an wir bauen und wir lassen uns
irgendwann jeder baum schöne gebäude
wird ein paar leuten die wir dann ein
laden immer hin und wieder und dann mit
dabei über interessante themen über
unsere meinung dazu
das ist einfach darum heißt es ja auch
nicht let's play sondern einfach die
today show und überhaupt die meinung zu
dem ganzen kopf sofort die
lizenzgebühren könnte es vielleicht
nutzen also 2 300 folge und 200 euro pro
folge aber das ist ein anderes thema das
ist ein anderes thema das auch noch was
wir erwähnen wollen dass die server
hiervon nitrate gesponsort werden
und also in der beschreibung ist auch um
einen link dazu und wir können gerade
nur empfehlen jetzt werde als hier sehen
wir sie als reibungslos läuft nah und
damit zwei drei klicks bekommt ihr
vielleicht wenig geld wir wollen das
mafia
vier euro für japan hat einen monat lang
vier slots für 10 oder 12 zloty oder
sonst wer für weniger tage aber ist ja
auch die preise auf deren seite sehen
sind einfach sind faire preise und es
können noch einfach nur empfehlen und
wenn wir wenn man sich im feld wenn ich
so was ich empfehlen könnte dann würde
es nicht machen und ist einfach deutlich
besser als wenn der über amateur zeugs
laufen ist wirklich deutlich
reibungsfrei kam er werde alles mögliche
wir hatten unseren alten server halt
auch schon bei nitrat und jetzt wollten
wir einfach noch mal kurz erwähnen und
was ich eigentlich sagen wollte war das
dmc auch aufnimmt das sieht ja jetzt
gerade an die zuschauer die das auf
seinem kanal sehen
ich nehme auch auf also wir nehmen das
beide auf wir werden das immer jede
folge kunden in den video antworten
verlinken dass sie quasi wenn ihr seht
ohne neue tv-show seht ihr sofort extra
das intro für ok die haben beide
aufgenommen also es ist halt schon
besser sortiert hoffe ich doch mal also
das sollte es zumindest sein und ich
glaub so langsam haben wir auch genug
holz ich glaube ich habe jetzt fast
einen stack insgesamt zu fasten stepper
setzlinge und dann wollten wir uns hier
ein bisschen niederlasse und versuchen
so ein bisschen flachland zu suchen das
sei ja ganz und leider ganz interessant
dass ich weiß nicht ob das langwierig
ist dieses flachland also groß aber
können einfach mal schauen vielleicht
mehr schon hier ordentlich weg ich habe
hier schicken gesehen habe muss ich
sofort annehmen hier was zu essen
sonntag ich habe gerade gesehen aber ist
es mir ich weiß ich sonst verliere ich
dich hab eine medaille hinterher sollte
sind wir hier sehr gut welche nie da
kommen wir dir mal die zwei eier mit und
kennen die beiden da haben wir nochmal
ein paar chicken wings ist ja ist auch
nicht ich machen wollte war übrigens
dass ich mich nicht nur das auch noch
ein bonbon bin ich denn hier ab ich
wollte mich natürlich erstmal haus an
die oberfläche aber ich möchte so einen
richtig riesigen keller bauen und in dem
keller möchte ich so noch wiesenflächen
machen
also ich hab da schon eine idee wie ich
es vielleicht umsetzen könnte
muss ich dann schauen ob ich das alles
verwirklichen kann aber erstmal
natürlich wollen wir sie ins flachland
bleibst du wenn jemand ein baum paula
sagt ich denke darüber nach wie blöd wie
eigentlich die ganze zeit ohne werkzeuge
abbauen aber
dabei immer von den großen häusern
träumen dahin werden wir machen ja
bergner
sie tauchen 22 wo ich ihn schlage
dadurch dass das war glaube ich irgendwo
eine falsche richtung das ist ein
bollwerk
ich bin nicht noten am not amused dass
ich hab nur gekitzelt das war ein fehler
weitreichend ist dieses flachland echt
groß dass sie zumindest hier ist ein
bisschen endlich sehr genial aus also
ich denke mal das war eigentlich so
geplant dass wir uns ein bisschen halt
in die mitte und zu beiden häuser setzen
und dann drumherum dann immer mit den
ganzen folgen com pariser von anderen
leuten halt dazu dann verbinden wir das
mit straßen mit sehen es wird
unglaublich schön
ja aber es ist ja immer ansehen du bist
hässlich
ja ich weiß wo ich meine ständig hat ich
fühle mich wundert nein ich meine das
ist immer ansichtssache wer bei schönem
wetter täglich findet da muss man
mittlerweile vorsichtig sein
nur weil wir das nicht schön finden
heißt dass nicht sofort dass er das auch
schon findet aber ich denke er hätte
durch abonniert wenn wir nicht so
ungefähr alle den gleichen geschmack
hätte hätten hätte ich meine das aber
zwei elemente der dich lass dich erst
mal töten müssen uns für später und
können uns europa ist eine höhle
wir wollen uns hier erstmalig wohin
bauen du dann lässt er sich gut an
hier ist ja eigentlich würde nämlich
auch schon
der tag erinnert sich dem ende bedeutete
ihr regiert das ist gar nicht gut das
ist überhaupt nicht gut du wir brauchen
ich würde sagen hier ist gut schafe
schafe schafe nicht alleine ich sehe gar
keine
es sollte so eine funktion geht mit
seiner survival welt dass man die erste
nacht vielleicht überspringen kann oder
die erste nach der erste tag allgemein
länger ist dafür sicher einstellen kann
oder die sache erstmal diesen riesengroß
wir schaffen das auch so auch erstmal
werkzeugen erstmal ein paar werkzeuge
nehmen übrigens nicht sind erst mal so
an der werse junge wir werden es so
machen dass wir ich sage mal und
zusammen irgendwohin sondern wir bauen
uns schon beides selben haus richtig
aber gemeinsame crafting ben schon dass
da auch daniel das ist meine die darf
nicht verwenden weil wegen darum weil
wegen brot ja das war dabei bei leuten
mit demonstrativ skin verschwörer
verwenden ja also genau jetzt ein
zwilling und so bin ich auch so bisher
alle natürlich warum muss mich immer
noch eine tolle szene ändern
naja egal was passiert ist aber ich esse
jetzt auf jeden fall ne menge tiere
ich lasse auf jeden fall weil wir solche
police sind aber nicht ob dies wohl
wir machen das ja auch auf easy und es
wird durchgehend isi seien wir stellen
das ist sind wir werden nichts verändern
die wir werden keine probleme haben mit
welten oder so dass man wie weg sind es
wurde gerade extrem dunkel bei mir
plötzlich und ich habe angst
bist du dass ich das wissen wer ich bin
auf dem weg zu dir
das ist sehr gut an und wo im boden
reinbauen also jeder selbst ja ich will
nur dass eine branche die nacht zur song
base halten
wir können ja holz mit holz verbrennen
oder ich hab kein rohholz wird mir egal
ich werde mich erst mal im boden graben
der vor allem mich erst einmal steigern
das auch hierzu schlucht gehen und hier
erstmal ein paar steine abbauen
du ich gerade mit dem boden und bunten
steine ab 1
das aber und altair ist eine welle der
ebene ist wahrscheinlich dieselbe das
ist hier so eine so ein höhen das ist ja
total blöd wenn ich mich über eine hürde
baut dann den wagen zur seite schrieb
erst mal so viele steine das irgendwie
ein ofen zusammenkratzen kann ja eben
ich traue mich nicht in die hülle ist so
dunkel und die ganze haushalt kommt erst
mal hier unten treiben
ich bin aber hat in dieser komischen
hülle und erst mal so so ein paar steine
ab dass ich mir werkzeuge aus stein
machen kann und so weiter ja also du
kannst du da wo ich reingegangen kann es
erstmal reinkommen ich hab uns hier eine
kleine basis errichtet das ist aber nett
von dir solche kohle abbauen weil die
liegt hier so offen
ich sehe sie nicht gut weil sie liegt
hier ich habe das im gefühl dass hier
was liegt macht das macht das darf jeder
weil es hier gerade extrem dunkel ist
bei mir
das ist übrigens gar keine richtige okay
doch es ist ich sehe ich bin direkt
neben die hier nach hier guck hier alle
wunderschön
hallo so kommen wir direkt in diesem
gang kicker mehr bleiben das sehr gut
übrigens haben uns auch gedacht wenn sie
sich wieder enorm quatschen von welchen
änderungen in den nächsten partien zu
themen kommen weil wir sind aber gerade
auch schon wieder bei zwölf minuten
ungefähr
ich habe übrigens eisen du hast weißt ja
hast du schon einstein spitzhacke du ich
hab da hinten crafting table da kann man
das machen
ihr studio erstmal so der papa hast du
noch ein bisschen kohle für mich dann
oder macht sofort zu schnell wie möglich
keine kohle da rausnehmen die da drin
ist wo ist da schon kisten achte bist du
so richtig am werkeln genannten nicht
dachte aber dieses kannst du hinten raus
nehmen aus dem ofen
ach so dass gott mir also die nächsten
folgen werden uns dann um ein paar
themen kümmern und so weiter auch durch
kohle gibt brand ich dazu erhält das ist
eine coole maschinerie hast du das
gemacht
dessen ab was geht da ab ob ich so klug
bin ja eben
ich hatte mich auch gefunden hat ich
mich auch schon etwas denkt dass ich gut
bin so da hinten sind auf jeden fall
zombies ich kann stehen jetzt erst mal
um ein schwert des fast kaputt ist
vielleicht eine gute idee
hast du überhaupt schon die
steinwerkzeuge ich mache jetzt erstmal
zwei stellen bergsteiger so gut dann mal
hier erstmal für mich steinegg zurück
gott der hat mich fokussiert er läuft
auf mich zu und mein schwert das kaputt
ich komme ich schaff das erhält ein
bisschen aus dass jetzt nicht und so
krippe oder ähnliches gezeugt getier ob
grün auf gelb ob zombie ob creeper oder
spinne der übrigens die letzte sache die
ich jetzt auch erwähnen wollte meine
lieben freunde wenn ihr mit bitte nicht
böse sein dass dabei nicht immer wenn
ich das so lese aber bitte nicht der zum
einen von wegen
die welt war doch so schön und es ist
doch gerade erst angefangen ja ich weiß
wir haben jetzt relativ früh beendet das
let's play together aber einfach bei mir
auf meinem kanal möchte ich natürlich
was neu machen und da wollen wir dann
auch diese to get a schon ganz gut
machen und ich glaube das passt in das
konzept eigentlich ganz gut rein
also ich denke es wird euch gefallen und
dann einfach mal abwarten
es werde auf jeden fall nicht 20 partien
sondern vergibt das bin ich verrecke
einfach nur es wird definitiv länger
gehen wollte sah so du tust du hast
hunger oder was hier im april april
apfel wachsen wie machtvoll kilo ich
habe mir noch voller hunger fast und
dann nadu verlangte schon ab ich bin vor
junge alter der na ja denn diese folge
ist jetzt sehr praktisch schon in
wenigen sekunden vorbei und können uns
ja abschließend jetzt mal ein feedback
für erste folge hier in die kommentare
schreiben
hoya oder mit wenn ihr wenn ihr eine
wenn ihr so buchstaben und so tippen
viel zu kompliziert es kann ja auch etwa
daumen hoch oder daumen runter je
nachdem wie soll die verein hat vorteile
das wird uns einfach dann als sagen ist
das konzept hier geil oder habt ihr
verbesserungsvorschläge und wir haben
damals haben wir sind ein wir haben
langhammer geschrieben habe lange
gesucht namen intro beziehungsweise
lange darum beschäftigt was wir nehmen
wie wir das aufbauen und ihr denkt jetzt
natürlich alles konzept an sich ist doch
total simpel da kommt man oft schnell
drauf wenn ihr das hört ist das
natürlich simpel wenn ihr irgendwie seht
fußball der sport an sich ist total
simpel aber so was essen auf die idee zu
kommen das ist das schwierige
erbschaften und den habe ich aber auch
fußball-fan baseballer finden rasch
gefunden
nein ich meinen koffer so was die
curling gefunden und ich meine dass
echten scheichs sportpsychologische
curling die presse erfunden
er gehört aber ganz schöne gehören also
das ist dass er so eine boxershort sport
ich glaub ich schere stein papier oder
so was erfunden bevor da da gibt es
übrigens taktiken ich habe im internet
nach geguckt weil wir oft so machen beim
fußball im jahresschnitt schnack schnuck
wer schießt den freistoß jetzt und dann
ja okay gut